for those of you who don't know or
didn't watch yesterday I'm playing an
over the board tournament in st. Louis
it's a 2019 norm Congress there's two
sections I am Section GM section I'm in
the item section it's a round-robin ten
players
nine rounds I was black I played an
opening that I've never played before I
was actually really excited going into
this game today because I I really
wanted to try out this opening I was
expecting exactly what she played d4
Knight f6 e4 and then I played Knight to
c6 and this is a line maybe I've played
like a little bit in me chest bullets
but this is a line yet you don't see too
often this is called the knight ting the
the the two Knights tango or the Black
Knight tango I don't even know the name
I think there's a Wikipedia article
about it looka pedia yeah Black Knights
tango what I'll do is all make a comment
here linking to the Wikipedia article
and the Wikipedia article is actually
useful because it listed off like a
bunch of grandmasters who played this
and it gave me like some Direction whose
gains to study like I was studying a lot
of polygons games so she started
thinking oh maybe I didn't mention I was
playing Rochelle Wu
who's very talented junior I think she's
like 13 years old this game was at least
four and a half hours and it took so
much like not only physical energy but
emotional energy like I was feeling good
in the beginning and then and I was
feeling terrible because I was dead and
then somehow I survived so she was
thinking here I think after the first
ten moves I got a pretty significant
time advantage she played Knight to c3
which is one of the main moves other
moves are Knight f3 or d5 also playable
d5 I think I would be happy with this
95 bucks ahead and developments east 6
is coming this is a bit overextended so
so 93 is reasonable
I play e5 she plays d5 and I've played
97 so the main point of this opening is
to get this sort of structure where
white is overextended a little bit and
the plan for black is very
straightforward Knight g6 developed the
Bishop d6 Castle
maybe someday later attack on the Kings
side so this is one of the things I was
preparing beforehand
she plays g3 which was slightly
unexpected it's I guess the first new
move that I had not considered before
the game I think I was prepared for like
efore Bishop g5 there's some interesting
line like he for my g 6h for this is
maybe one of the more testing lines
black has to play h5 and then ship g5
but she played g3 the solid move so I
play Knight g6 the knight was maybe not
the happiest because it's restricted by
the pawn but I want to develop my bishop
so Bishop g2 is [ __ ] before Bishop d2
now she actually set up this trap it's
one of the most natural looking moves
looks like d6 but this just blunders to
Queenie for this is an idea that I'd
actually like seen beforehand in
preparation so I knew not to go into
this and I was debating here whether to
castle or do something else and I didn't
want a castle immediately because after
h4 h5 my rook wants to be on h8 kind of
supporting the pawn at least that's what
I thought so I wanted to stay flexible
I played a5 defending my Bishop and
preparing g6 also preventing any later
Queen side expansion so she plays d4
natural move d6 92 Bishop g4
I think around this point I wanted to
play h5 and if I get in each for then
life would be very good but she can play
h4 and yeah I was fantasizing a little
bit about this line Knight g4 castling
castling and then Knight takes h4 takes
takes and this looks potentially really
fun I probably would have gone for this
if it wasn't for f3 so after f3 I just
have to move back and it's kind of a
waste of time so I play Bishop g4 h3
Bishop g7 so I provoked h3 so if she
castles I could play queen c8 with tempo
she played Queen c2 and then I played
Queen c8 I was feeling decent because
Queen ca prevents flight from castling
the rook is tied down to the h-bomb and
then I wasn't entirely sure what she was
going to do and then she surprised me
with queenside castling which is I mean
it looks very strange but maybe it's
playable like I already have my pollen a
5 I have ideas of c6 ideas of b5 it seem
like I have a lot of potential to attack
but then she told me after the game that
she wants to fire for here and attack me
so it's still like pretty sharp so I
play c6 I was still playing pretty
quickly I was I mean all my move so far
have been very natural I was actually
inspired by Fabiana Caruana to play this
line he played this a few times in the
crow chess league and he had very good
results just playing like really quickly
like all these thematic ideas so Bishop
g5 Queen c7 the Queen c7 was idea I
think my idea was to play rook c8
takes and put some pressure on the file
also maybe someday Queen to to be six so
King b1 got very natural patient because
now if I play rook c8 or if I take and
play rook c8 there's not as much
pressure also there is some issue here
that if I take on d5 well white can take
on f6 takes takes and this is just
really bad for black Queens attacks
pawns attacks the square is just in full
control for wings so I play 97 with idea
to take and not allow white to get this
like monstrous night so Bishop takes f6
pawn takes f6 and a3 let's get to the
critical moments Bishop c5 f4 and then I
take ya this is a very critical moments
White's a move there's a few different
options here well I can take with uh not
with her work with either pawn or with
the night and during the game I was
thinking she would take with the Knights
hitting this pawn I would take she would
take back probably with this pawn and
then I felt like Bach is slightly better
with the two bishops maybe there's ideas
of Queen b6 or even like be five well
what she played in the game was pawn
takes pawn and in this position I play
the move which I thought was just
crushing and it should be the best move
and maybe I'll pose this to the the
chat's block to move find find the best
move oh you tried to pause the video has
is this twitching not YouTube yeah for
the people watching in the future on on
YouTube you can pause the video okay so
the suggestions are not f5 Bishop f5 and
Bishop e3 so far
I played one of these moves I played
night at five few people saying Bishop
f5 which I don't think is as effective
if I played this about five days Bishop
efore and bishops neutralized well after
9f5
there's basically this unstoppable move
ninety three it's just a square in
White's territory I fully control I hit
the I'm planning to hit the rook the
Queen and the bishop and the pawn it's
like a quadruple fork and whites cannot
prevent me from playing Knight c3 or
Knight e3 so I thought I was winning
material here and then she started to
put up resistance so she played Queen d3
which is actually very useful it gets
the Queen out of danger and defends upon
then after I play 93 she plays rook g1
so I'm not winning any material but it
still looks very good for black and I
thought I mean I thought I should have
something here my bishops aligned with
the rook there's potential for a Bishop
f5 well I couldn't find anything like
super clear cuts because still Bishop f5
there's Bishop b4 I mean I could move my
knight somewhere and attack the rook but
I can't really take either pawn if I
move back and the rook just moves back
so I played what I thought was the best
move pawn f5 going for Pawnee 4 and
Pawnee 4 is actually a really annoying
threats because I would hit the Queen
that we drive the Queen away from
defending this pawn and I'm just winning
the pawn so she has to still defend she
takes I take still threatening e4 and
then she plays a knight d1 which I
completely overlooked my t1 was was a
nice move now the issue is that my
knight is just it has to trade itself
off I can't I can't leave the night here
and this is something I forgot about
when she plays rook t1 these ideas of
playing this and I just assumed
it's like I'd have some tactic against
this rook but yeah I didn't see anything
and now I can't play E 4 E 4 is actually
a blunder here because Queen C 3 and
this is hanging as well as this is
hanging Z Mads thanks for subbing so I
know it still looks crushing I did what
I thought was only moved and I takes G
to rook takes G to and kind of something
weird happened where I liked my position
for a while and then at some points I
didn't like my position and then she was
just completely crushing me she was also
very low on time so it could have been
that I was playing perhaps too much rice
playing different moves and like trying
to complicate things to take advantage
of the time situation but then it kind
of backfired but but yeah I have the
bishop here I have these pawns I don't
know how good it is for black because my
King is still a little bit in the center
White's pieces are not so coordinated is
it Knight takes Knight either yeah if I
take the knight I mean it's another
option
I thought leaving the knight on d1 was
just more effective or just led to
better chances for me and the bishops
not so powerful either but yeah this is
playable
I took the bishop I like the two bishops
versus two knights dynamic she takes I
play rook CH I was happy about rook c8
because I'm still having ideas c4 isn't
the easiest pawn to defend she plays
rook e1 and then I Castle yeah in
hindsight I mean I thought castling was
a best way to protect my King Rubik on
on thanks for subbing three months I
think I was considering something like
this Bishop d6 took the pawn
but then there's 93 and like then I can
very quickly get active
so I Castle it's kind of late to Castle
this is move 24 la usually you should
castle within the first 10 mins I'm
counseling into a structure which isn't
the most safe
I go lying with the rook and these
double pawns I figured the G file can't
be opened by force I guess g4f for
that's actually what happened
g4 f4 I was feeling good here I mean
these pawns are are actually both passed
pawns I have the bishop here and I was
thinking both bishops are actually quite
good like this Bishop works together
with the pawns this Bishop will help
maybe later control the light squares I
was having ideas of King eh Aiden f5 and
get the bishop to the diagonal of the
opponent's king and queen so I think she
coped with this quite well though like
she played Knight c3 okay most natural
move I play King h8 and then she plays
mighty four and then the move that I
initially wanted to play I don't think
works and maybe I'll pose this as
another question I really wanted to play
off five here I mean I five looks so
juicy so we imagine okay if takes takes
my bishop is aligned if if takes takes I
mean it looks so great for a white this
is hit I think there's there's one
problem is that after it takes takes
there's incredible move for white in
this position Knight takes off for and
the problem becomes my King is is
actually a target in many variations and
she would just win a pawn here and if I
take the knight
I just got needed a queen c3 this is
force mate
my king has nowhere to go so I feel so
random like the Queen checks along the
diagonal I have nothing to balk with all
these blocking moves I can block on
every single square but no square is so
fishing defended it's so sad also same
line applies like if takes she can dig
with her rock and after it takes take
sticks it's the same thing
I'm just getting mated so I really
wanted to play a5 but I don't think it
works because it might takes off for so
I I had to come up with a plan B I
played f6 I was hesitant to play this
like and Feingold was in the back of my
mind never play f6 but I felt like it
was a reasonable move like just secure
the pawns like the pawn structure is
very solid there's less tactics along
this diagonal now that the F pawn
obstructs any potential checks and I was
still feeling decently I also have ideas
of Bishop eh to g6 so I still want to
get my Bishop along this diagonal so she
played d6
it's caught me a little bit off guard
like at first I thought this was just
bad but then she means she found an
amazing way to justify it I'm actually
curious like how much he thought ahead
because if she if she played d6 knowing
what was coming next and be very
impressive Queen c6 but she probably did
actually because it was very very
forcing Knight takes f4 at first I
thought this doesn't work like I just I
play that six to stop this idea the
problem is that after takes she takes on
c5 and then if I take with the Queen I'm
just losing like rookie 7 this diagonal
is no longer a problem but this h7 pawn
is a huge problem
rar yeah
OD chess so f6 was like an attempt to
defend but I guess f6 opened up the the
7th rank so maybe it was Karma
like the ghost of been Feingold just
making sure justice is served
obviously I saw this I didn't allow this
to happen
I think I'm just getting made here
though cuz now if I play at five I was
checking in life isn't fair so yeah when
she took on that four I started
calculating and I was realizing oh
there's some trouble so I decided to
take and after it takes I had a very
nifty move Bishop Yates I thought it's
still good for me I thought okay I'm
threatening Bishop g6 I'm threatening
the rook which I forgot to mention I
could take the rook in this position too
but they're still rookie seven like this
idea is so strong and again f5 there's
Queen D for Queen g1 doesn't do anything
and like I would really want to take on
h3 the defend of the Queen defends h3
anyway we got to this position so I
can't take the knight I can't take the
rook both because rook here just
destroys me so I play Bishop yet I was
still feeling good I have like three
threats I'm threatening this this and
this and I'm no longer scared of rookie
seven because of Bishop g6 and she plays
94 back so she saves everything like 94
is nice smooth I was still feeling good
cuz she had maybe a minute or two here
and I had about 15 to 20 minutes but
then I started taking time because I
realized it wasn't so easy like this
Knights capture my next move this knight
is pinned in two directions
well I'm temporarily down upon my Kings
side is still a bit weak and her moves
become very easy I shoot I think she was
able to play precisely here because it
was just a matter of defending against
simple threats 31d 731 d7 in this
position od
seven in this position I can take it I
believe or wait no 31 d7 I would play I
would play Bishop g6 Jack and then next
move I can decide between taking the
rook or moving my own room what do I
normally prefer an easy win or a
hard-fought loss depends how much money
is on the line all right it should Yeats
so we get to this position my time
situation is good I have initiative but
she started playing good moves
b3 defending the pawn I play rook cdas
maybe this was a mistake I didn't see
what else I didn't see anything like so
promising I was thinking rook e8
all right thinking f3 here maybe I
should have played off three I didn't
want to commit to giving away my pawn so
early well why would have to take and
then I can take here
attacking this pawn I kind of rejected
this because white has easy moves like
King b2 I'm still down the pond this is
tender maybe there's some initiative
like Queen check
oh wait Queen Jack and then like rook
the problem is whenever I put a truck on
the edge he just plays rookie to like
maybe a four it's very tricky
I'm sure if at some point I'll I'll take
a look at stock fish and it will find
something for black maybe somewhere but
yeah things got a little bit complicated
because white was holding on to the
extra pawn and here I play off three
after it takes takes we just traded
pawns and I'm still down the pawn is
rook g8 after king each eights bad I
want my work on that file to help
support that fun
and the G file wasn't so valuable for me
so the game continued I'm I was down the
pawn but I felt like I still have
compensation like this Knight is still
kind of pinned but then she fight a
really good move Knight d2 which I sort
of overlooked it's not the end of the
world I take she can't trade Queens
because I have this injured meso
if takes takes your rook c2 very
important and then I pick up the Queen
or even yeah I'm just winning material
multiple ways
oops so yeah ninety-two we trade and at
this point I was still playing for a win
I still had massive time advantage
she was playing on increments by
covering around a minute on the clock so
she plays Queen c3 this is very nice
move protecting the King targeting both
pawns now I play Queen g1 I was still
optimistic I wanted to have ideas of
this guy's hoping this light would move
so I could just meets and get some food
that didn't happen
rookie six attacking the pawn and the
problem was it was hard to make progress
like my bishop and queen are perfectly
placed or so I thought and my rook is
tied down like I really want to play
this and like add one more attacker but
I just didn't have the time so I play
Kings yet I was trying to prepare a
rookie a rookie 6oj I give spoilers I'm
sorry I mean the result is already here
but the way the game was drawn was
really crazy I'll put this on training
mode again Queen d1 why didn't she play
39 85 oh why didn't she take on a5 if
she takes on a5
that's a good question his queen D for
Queen C 3 I think I was preparing this
Queen D 1 threatening this which leads
to me she would have to go back and then
I would play rook d8 and I'm pretty sure
the attack is now overwhelming like
there's no good way to deal with this oh
but maybe there's this but 94 I of
Queenie - no it's still complicated I
think this is winning though the king
was back I mean I just win if Queen C -
I can take and play this and this is
should be winning so a 5 pawn was I mean
I was hoping she would take it cuz I
mean it looks like a free pawn that
gives me just enough initiative to
probably win so so I play Queen d1 here
trying to tie white down like I thought
white was really stuck here like the
knight spin to the rook also pinned down
to defending be won the Queen's tied
down to the things you - so she played
this move Queen c1 I played Queen e2 and
then she moved back so this is
essentially offering me a draw like if I
played here I would imagine you'd repeat
I was trying to win and in this position
I was a little bit self-destructive and
I played a 4 I thought a 4 should be a
good like inclusion I was expecting d4
and then I would move back to d1 and
like try and keep the game going but
then she played very cold-blooded move
he takes a 4 which I assumes is playable
but I thought I would just win the pawn
back I thought now I can get ready to
take the pawn but then she played a very
strong move here and so move which I
probably should have seen coming but
like in the heat of the situation I just
kind of forgot about she played c5
see five friends to trade Queens trading
Queens is the last thing I want to do in
this position I given if I win this pawn
queen me three and this is a pretty bad
endgame for black I mean there's two
pawns this pawn is difficult to hold on
to so I really wanted to eat Queens on
the board
so I played Queen each one trying to
just find the square for my queen that
doesn't allow a trade I defended you
seven from a distance i attack h3 I'm
still hanging b1 I've added use of queen
h2 and then then she she just completely
outplayed me from here
a5 simple patient move basically calling
my bluff that I don't really have a
threat I tell you Ricky eight when she
plays g5 strong move takes even what
else to do
and then rook d7 driving mates yeah
something went seriously wrong I
probably should have taken the like
repetition when I had the chance the
point of g5 is to remove this pawn from
obstructing the Queen and and get to the
g7 square so I pretty much have to take
and then white starts threatening mates
and it's it's not easy so yeah I play
Bishop f7 I mean this is the only way to
defend and then Queen f6 so at this
point every move felt like a punch in
the face like g5 was a punch Queen f6 is
a punch
just getting slaughtered and now this is
a threat this is a threat now I I tried
not to look at the engine like after the
game but I took a peek at the engine I
remember I think stockfish said like -
or know it's it's +7 here like why it's
just completely crushing
but somehow I like given the time
situation I was able to put up some
resistance i play rook a fates I mean I
have to defend my bishop Queen takes g5
why do you not like looking at the
engine I don't mind looking at the
engine but I I like to just use my brain
of why I'd be lazy and just see like
what the computer spits out because it's
always interesting to like arrive at
your own conclusions and then see like
everything you missed afterwards so if
people want to analyze this with engine
and see maybe how wrong I was about
certain moments I'm leaving the study
link in the chat I do encourage people
especially when reviewing like their own
games to try and arrive at your own
conclusions and then later come back
with engine if you have enough time okay
so I was feeling pretty sad might has
any sort of perpetual but clearly going
for a win 94 is a very strong move ideas
of 9 f6 Queen g2 rooked you - I don't
have any checks Knight f6 is coming and
like when I saw this ahead of time so I
saw this physician coming I thought it
was just gonna need that lost I have one
move here which keeps me alive kind of
Queen g7 and the point is that if Knight
f6 King h8 and then I'm alive kind of
I'm sure there's ways to win I mean rook
rook d7 is probably just winning
actually rook d7 could be a beautiful
win I didn't see this in the game Oh
blocks completely tied down like White
has some simple idea like just promotes
either pawn this Queen can move the ship
can't move because alignment
maybe the rook could move but can't
really go anywhere that creates
[Music]
yeah it's not easy and with like when
you get a winning position to actually
converts she traded Queens which i think
is very practical takes and then rook F
to yeah I think maybe around here there
were some other options for whites maybe
rook t7 expecting or 57 96 trying in the
pawn as quickly as possible I was gonna
play this and then I mean I think she
can just take and play this and it
should just be winning what happened in
the game I was able to hold on to the
b-pawn I started with rook 8 96 and then
Bishop d5 so I saved my vision I saved
the pawn these plans are weak and I
started having hope she played rook d2
Bishop f3 and then she played a play the
move some of it I just forgot about but
we were both very low on time at this
points we both had like a minute or two
left with increments so wait to move in
this position what move did white play
that I forgot about which is kind of a
fancy but simple tactic I'll let people
try and find it over to which says check
with the Knights
yeah checking with the Knights it's a
candidate move but strongest move Knight
takes b7 and I thought I felt really sad
here because I thought I was just gonna
lose like I've lost a pawn bishop takes
b7 there's rook check and like I wanted
to play rook pH but then a6 and like any
position we get like this it's just
winning for whites so I played the only
move which I thought would give me like
a sliver slither of hope is to play rook
a7 attacking the knight trying to remove
the night so I can win this pond
and then then she played night th which
I was expecting and then I played Bishop
to e4 so I'm holding on like this Knight
is actually restricted by my bishop and
this pawn is hanging and she plays c6 I
play King f6 and somehow it like it was
a little bit confusing and I think
because of the time situation yeah white
didn't find the best approach now that
I'm looking at it
oh wait 97 Oh 97 is what she played
maybe white you just might should just
turn on stockfish see what the best move
is maybe rook d7 rook d7 doesn't look
right
takes chicks
maybe there's a six here like a six
takes and then c7 it's a very confusing
position so type of thing like might
have to spend some time and calculates
well there was really not much time for
either of us so she played Knight d7
which looks natural defending the pawn
idea if take then rook d6 but after I
take which which is what was played rook
d6 give me five takes takes this is a
really difficult position for white to
win because even though White's up to
pawns
there's only rook pawns and now we get
into some endgame territory and we got
into some like very than a theoretical
endgame which I don't know how much time
I want to spend on because it was a long
battle and at some point we reached some
like table based position okay so this
is not table base yet if you guys don't
know sure most of you know but any chess
position with seven or fewer pieces is
solved and right now I believe there's
there's eight pieces so once another
plan comes off Lee chess will know the
exact results with perfect play it's a
useful tool very interesting tool for
situations like like what's about to
happen so she plays rook d6 I played
okay seven and a six
I mean I thought I was gonna lose at
this point I thought some I mean it's
hard like my rook is so passive
positions like this you you want an
active rook that I have to stop the pawn
so King d4 king b3 so I moved my king
rook d7 actually surprised me a little
bit was expecting work h6
Poseidon's still probably winning tipsy
time yeah I had a good position earlier
in the game but I I don't know she
played well I I still don't know like
where my opportunity was I'm sure
stockfish knows but okay rook g2 Haruka
p7 takes okay so now to show this
physician is solved
I'm guessing it's winning for whites
well let's see yeah rook takes h7 so
it's winning for white yeah luckily for
me it's maybe not the most intuitive way
so hopefully this will be instructive
like how to how to try and survive a
position like this as black it's for me
I just kind of have to wait around and
try and prevent life from making
progress white starts pushing pushing me
down the board trying to work the way
with a pond so a for cha-ching b5 King
b7 is this a table base try think this
is still winning
was there a draw earlier no this is all
when you yeah the problem is that my
king can only help guard one pawn at a
time
so I think the winning strategy if I had
to explain it in like a kind of a more
strategic overview why he wants to push
one pawn and use it as a decoy to
distract the king and then walk the King
to other side and then promote the other
pond but in order to do so you have to
kind of you have to make sure the other
pawn is far enough advanced and I think
one of them is mistakes she made wasn't
not advancing the pawn far enough
like the pawn stayed on h3 until it was
too late it's rookie four was not played
why not trade rooks and promote the
pawns there is no chance to trade rooks
she tried to trade rooks she tried with
rook d7 but of course when you're black
and you're down
upon you don't want to trade off or in
this case down to plants Aquila good to
see you back Aquila I'm doing okay I'm
playing a tournament stressful I somehow
survives this this endgame so going
forward here I'll go the quicker yeah I
think in this physician this is like the
table based moments where yeah she
should start with like h4 the pollen
should kind of work their way up
together
she played a5 which I don't fully
understand like somehow it's drawing
after I really don't understand this
like okay rook beam on is logical but
Brooke f3 the other drawing move I
really don't understand rook f3 because
H for happens so I'll have to dig
through this was a later point to try
and understand this but for now um okay
she played h5 I played rook c1 I thought
this was logical I cut off the king
apparently it's it's a losing move but
then and she play a six and I think this
is a point where it should be a draw
like a six was was premature like a five
should still be winning the problem was
that after a six a king has no shelter
and I just started checking and I can
like if the king goes too far this way I
can simply attack the pawn so what ended
up happening is check here attack the
pawn she played a seven if she plays
King here here I just check again and
after a seven there's a very nice kind
of drawing idea
h4 check King d5 because now she's
trying the strategy like okay I can't
take the pawn and now she wants to go
and promote this pawn so I'll leave this
as a final test for the chat's black to
move what's the easiest way to draw
rook d3 check is unfortunately illegal
but I think I know what you mean
rookie six okay most people are saying
it correctly rook d6 check this is what
we call the crazy rook or the nad rook
the rook will continually give checks
the King has nowhere to hide so what
ended up happening check check and this
is how the game finished check then she
tried one trick also this is a very like
kind of typical idea in positions where
you might be dead lost but like this is
your last trick this is why if you're
playing on from a lost position you want
to leave yourself with like a rook or a
queen and try and achieve a situation
like this where you you sacrifice your
last major piece to stalemate your
opponent's in this case I I force the
sacrifice or it's just perpetual just a
last trick here is that when the King
goes to h5 I I have to I have to play
the right rook move so again I'll leave
it to the chat black to move shall I
play rook h6 Brook g5 there's a very big
difference between these moves sure this
is gonna be very easy for a lot of
people recession
I'd be tragic get all this way and then
just resign oh I ran out of checks time
to give up okay ruff g5 yeah the problem
with rook h6 again the rook takes and
unstable meets me so this is a one-trick
you have to be aware of chess we've in
the chat saying such a savage rook yeah
that's a nice way to finish it's why
this pawn pawn got you far and this pawn
was a little too slow declared war yeah
so it was a crazy game I mean I guess
here's what I'll do because I'm gonna
put this on youtube so for the YouTube
audience hope you guys enjoy that I'll
leave a link in the video description so
you can click and analyze on your own
leave your comments below if you have
any questions feel free to talk amongst
yourselves and I'll see you in the
future